ضوء الصباح كشف الدمار الذي خلفه القصف
الاسرائيلي على مناطق واسعه في قطاع غزه
بعد اعلان وقف اطلاق النار معظم الغارات
الاسرائيليه استهدفت مواقع للمقاومه يمنع
تصويرها او اراضي زراعيه لكن الاقتضاب
السكاني في غزه جعل المناطق السكنيه
المحيطه بالاماكن المستهدفه عرضه للاضرار
وسقوط الضحايا نار الحمراء شفتها من
2008 لهلقيت فش عنا حد يعني احنا ليش يعني
هذا الوضع ماساوي لنا رعب الاطفال خاف
وانا قلت ماتوا اللي في الدار ماتوا ولادي
وحال صرت اسرك يا فلان وينك
تعود الحياه تدريجيا في المناطق التي
تضررت من القصف الاسرائيلي لكن ذلك لا
يعني انتهاء معاناه سكان القطاع اذ يخشى
الناس ان يتعرضوا مجددا وفي اي وقت للقصف
ومحاولات الحكومه الاسرائيليه الاستمرار
العبث في الصواعق التفجير في المشهد
الفلسطيني وفي الساحه الفلسطينيه مستمره
تهديدات والترويح بمزيد من تصدير الازمات
داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه الى المشهد
الفلسطيني لا تزال قائمه ويبدو اننا امام
مزيد من التصعيد خلال المرحله القادمه اذا
ما استمرت هذه الحكومه الفاشيه في محاولات
العبث في المشهد الفلسطيني قد تكون هذه
الجوله من التصعيد الميداني في قطاع غزه
انتهت بتدخل الوسطاء لكنها لم تنهي اسباب
اندلاعها او تخفف من المخاوف من نوايا
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه التي تنظر
بالمزيد من الازمات
ليل قطاع غزه كان عنيفا
سلسله غارات اسرائيليه امتدت لساعات ورد
الفصائل الفلسطينيه باطلاق صواريخ تجاه
المناطق والمستوطنات الاسرائيليه تواصل
حتى ساعات الفجر غضبا على استشهاد الشيخ
خضر عدنان المقاومه الفلسطينيه فرضت قواعد
اشتباك على في الصراع مع العدو الصهيوني
القصف سيقابله قصف الاعتداء سيقابله
اعتداء المقاومه الفلسطينيه لن تتردد لن
تستسلم ستقوم بواجباتها ومسؤولياتها وهي
في مواجهه مستمره لا يمكن ان تتوقف ولا
تنتهي الا بزوال الاحتلال
بواسطه عده اطراف اوقفت تصعيد لكنه لم
يتضمن الاشاره الى امكانيه تسليم جثمان
الشهيد او حتى التخفيف من الاجراءات
العقابيه عن الاسرى في السجون الاسرائيليه
هبه عكيلا الجزيره من مدينه غزه